da ragazzo ho vissuto quello che era
le tradizioni lusi i modi di coltivare
la terra di coltivare gli animali e di
colpe di come trasformare i nostri
prodotti
poi negli anni sessanta è venuto 70 è
venuto questo grande cambiamento di
evoluzione di di cose più moderne e
maggiormente è stato l'uso della chimica
anticrittogamici antiparassitari e l'uso
di macchine potenti quello che vuole
dire è quello che ho conosciuto che
nelle epoche
di quando era giovane la terra si può
dire che veniva accarezzata da
dall'agricoltore veniva lavorata avuto
una profondità piccola in modo che
l'utilizzo di quello che gli animali con
gli escrementi lasciavano nel terreno
poi era fertilizzante e rende la terra
fertile per produrre poi cereali ed
altri prodotti
il nostro territorio aveva una tecnica
di lavorazione abbastanza omogenea quasi
tutti gli agricoltori facevano più o
meno le stesse cose
c'era un proverbio che dice va a casa
per quanto stai vigna per quanto baby e
terra per quanto vedi in modo voleva
dire che la gestione del territorio non
fosse tanto sobbalzata come oggi no oggi
purtroppo si decide di mettere la vigna
se ne mette a centinaia di ettari
poi dopo dieci anni la vigna non va più
bene ci mette le nocciole a centinaia
letteri e domani non andranno quelle si
ricorderà le radici proprio del
territorio il sistema di come utilizzare
questo territorio perché secondo me il
valore è di utilizzare quello che il
territorio è come l'uomo un insegnante
va a scuola
l'operaio l'ingegnere disdegna la casa
la terra ai suoi limiti e quindi non
scavalcarne mai i limiti della terra
l'insegnamento avuto da giovane è che
l'uomo nella terra ci viveva in simbiosi
si potrebbe dire faceva parte del suo
essere la terra quindi la la la
coltivava con cura
io mi ricordo che quando veniva seminato
un campo venivano fatti solchi che
avrebbero accompagnato dall'acqua al
fosso c'era cura del fosso c'era cura
degli animali gli animali
sono dei periodi dove potrebbero star
liberi nei campi e dove dovevano essere
nei ricoveri la grande e io lo chiamate
definita la regina degli animali in
maremma è stata la pergola perché poi la
pecora è stata quella che ha portato la
gente in questo territorio di maremma
fine degli anni sessanta si veniva tutti
da eredi transumanti che venivano
dall'appennino quindi la cultura della
pastorizia è è dentro il nostro dna si
può dire e la cultura della pastorizia
era quella che poi aveva dato a quella
grande cultura dell'agricoltura perché
rispetto degli animali poi voleva dire
anche il rispetto del territorio ormai
era la cosa affascinava affascinava a
tutti io ho poi ho conosciuto questo
periodo nelle quali i tecnici ci
consigliavano che di dare concimi
chimici
mi ricordo che c'era una volta uno mi
disse vedi fernando se tu dal terreno
prendi 30 quintali di grano 30 quintali
di grano dentro il cavo cioè il ferro
insomma tutte quelle sostanze che il
grano ha portate via dalla terra per far
questo prodotto che ci rimetti cimetti
concimi e l'anno dopo tiri da 30
quintali di grano e invece non è così ci
siamo accorti che fino che il grano era
frutto della terra è frutto di quel
passaggio degli animali che io lo definì
lo scarto di lavorazione degli animali
quel prodotto che ti pignata la terra
era salubre era genuino si può dire poi
invece continuamente concimi chimici
diserbanti antiparassitari il terreno
come dire se avvelenato e quindi ce lo
rivende in qualche modo io ho sempre
detto che la natura
se la offendi si vendica non è che la
natura si vendica siamo noi che ci
facciamo
rivendicare poi un'altra cosa che ho
notato è che ora dopo 50 anni si sta
riallacciando erano re i semi prima
degli anni sessanta i semi erano semi
curati dall uomo sempre per innesti
senza avere subito bombardamenti di
trasformazione quindi quegli alimenti
noi il nostro nostro organismo aveva con
vedere nei secoli assimilati da sempre
non creavano allergie
con questi strumenti soprattutto che per
dargli sempre più così mi avevano
abbassato lo spero che fossero più bassi
così potevi da più concime che non si
allettavano poi sul mercato questi
prodotti hanno dato dei problemi perché
oggi si sente tante persone intolleranti
vii ac intolleranti al glutine entrare
dati alle farine perché quelle non so
naturali perché quella è la chimica la
rese come dire in un certo senso quasi
nocive all'essere umano al nostro modo
di assorbirle queste queste sostanze e
questo secondo me la prospettiva
dovrebbe essere quella di in qualche
modo si usa dire fare un passo indietro
in questo modo forse vi dicono un passo
né perché si va troppo verso
allontanarsi da quello che che la natura
e i nostri avi attraverso tante
selezioni hanno dato la natura non può
essere più naturale sarebbe un'utopia
dire che si vive con le bacche o co o
con le erbe selvatiche
se siamo se siamo evoluti
se l'uomo è voluto dall'età della pietra
da oggi qualche cosa deve cambiare anche
nel rapporto con la terra
ma questo non vuol dire non rispettarla
perché se noi con la terra cita un
rapporto di amicizia di d
la terra poi a noi ci renderà
quell'affetto diciamo che li cita ma se
noi saremo violenti col territorio poi
la terra ce lo rivende questa violenza
ma allora bisognerà fa qualche passo
indietro modo che cece riva da
riconoscere l'importanza della
pastorizia sul territorio che è la cosa
principale perché l'uomo il primo
animale che ha allevato e che
addomesticate la perla quindi vuol dire
che anche milioni di anni fa già avevano
concepito il valore di questo animale la
pecora in animale che dà la carne latte
il formaggio pero consumi dentro anche
dopo un anno e che dà anche da vestiti
la lana quindi a un animale complesso
nel territorio e poi lo scarto di
lavorazione lo lascia nel terreno e
quindi di creare un humus e saprà meno
in un certo senso declivio dell'acqua
della terra perché se la terra è ricca
di humus e l'acqua delle piogge e la
portano via meno rapporto
dell'agricoltore sul territorio deve
ritornare in qualche modo per forza ad
essere come dire può curare le piante
avere amore per le piante nei campi le
siepi purtroppo è stato tolto troppo i
nostri avi quando si sporcavano lo
facevano proprio qui in simbiosi con la
terra quindi avevano rispetto delle
pietre del legno e delle piante perché
ora qui non si vede più quello che c'era
ma io lo posso lì in ogni campo in ogni
appezzamento di terreno
c'erano alberi di tutte le qualità che
servivano alberi da foglia che servivano
per gli animali durante periodi di
siccità dettaglia le piante fa mangiare
la foglia all'animale poi c'erano alberi
da frutto
voi vi posso dire che qui in questi
territori cent'anni fa la frutta c'era
365 giorni l'anno senza frigoriferi
perché c'erano varietà di di peri
innestati che da iniziavano da giugno e
finiva in a novembre con quelle con
quelle stagionali che duravano fine ma
finora fine maggio c'era la frutta
quindi vorrei concludere dicendo che sia
al progresso ma con molta attenzione
perché se ci si allontana troppo dai dai
nostri fondamenti dalle nostre basi
progredire con più attenzione in modo
che ci possa permettere di progredire
dilazionando il progresso in un tempo
maggiore in modo che che ci si possa far
seguirlo se io do documentare i tre
quintali cinque quintali di conoscerlo
in un ettaro di terreno poi quello lì
riparte va anche nel fiume
quindi c'è un inquinamento anche più dei
fiumi del mare se questo territorio
aveva una cultura che erano gli animali
o il grano in un certo modo se si carica
troppo di culture intensive vigna
snoccioli o qualsiasi altra cosa poi la
pioggia nel fiume ci porterà quello che
trova nella terra quindi secondo me è
molto da fare molta attenzione a questi
aspetti insomma credo che di avervi
detto qualcosa di quello che so potrei
parla molto di più per tre ore e
allargare come si dice il concetto di
quello che è il nostro ambiente perché
poi io parlo dell'ambiente
non parlo solo dell'agricoltura perché
quando dico che se si usa troppi troppi
insetticidi poi finiscono gli insetti
che si è guardato ieri che ci hanno
seguito per secoli a fianco dell'uomo
per darci il miele le api che è un
frutto che sa sembrerebbe immediato ma
tutti quegli altri impollinatori poi se
ci fossero noi finirebbe la nostra
esistenza quindi
l'ambiente a di tutti poi non è che è
dei contadini e quello che io voglio
esporre mi voglio esporre con la forza
di di conservare l'ambiente
principalmente perché al di fuori di lì
ci siamo
come dire tutti i fritti se l'ambiente
cede come sta accedendo perché l'italia
poi è una foglia con troppa acqua frana
dappertutto
queste sono le conseguenze
dell'abbandono della collina e della
montagna
sennò la gente no non trova un qualche
cosa che lo solidifica a ritornare nella
collina e della montagna tra pochi anni
l'italia sarà come l'impasto quasi tutta
acqua frana tutto siamo siamo a questi
livelli e questo so per tutti insomma va
bene
vi ringrazio dell'attenzione
dai